for this movie you kind of did some
research on the mythology the history of
witches yeah yeah what did you learn
well I've I've been fascinated about
which is my entire life all the way back
in school learning about the Salem witch
trials all of that it's always been
fascinating to me and one thing that I
learned that I just find so incredible
apparently the reason we have the myth
of witches flying on broomsticks right
that always seemed very strange and
arbitrary to me yeah why broomstick yeah
are they flying yeah apparently they
used this as centuries ago they used to
make a kind of salve with hallucinogenic
properties and that could be applied
many different ways but they found that
the direct blood stream would be hang on
everyone they would apply the salve to
the end of a broomstick and apply it to
their vaginas and it would make them
hallucinate hence flying witches can you
say vagina on this channel yeah yeah
it's more than what a broomstick yeah
yeah that's that's the insertion of
gnomes no no it's fine it's really not
the sweet Halloween tale it's not yeah
let me talk about the origin so do you
think there's any so they're actually
saying that that came from people women
obviously experimenting with with
witness hallucinogen using and then that
turned into Wow because they were flying
medically present it turned it became
yet it was like sort of translated into
being right actually flying but for
years they've been pictured riding it
wrong yeah
I suppose you could also you know write
it and apply it right okay Andy I was
almost hold it because I came it got
into an area that's I consider my job
description
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy japanese pornography